hitting on that point I watched a video
of yours again last night yeah I went I
would did a deep dive I really I wanted
to be I did I did in in 2018 of October
ha ha ha you're the video where you will
how long will I live in Japan for in
that video you were like maybe like
another three years right we're getting
close to that point Chris and I was
wondering like what are your thoughts
about that now yeah or is this gonna be
something discussed in a video you know
there's no there's still no plans to be
honest like before I leave the one thing
I always want to do is to film a short
film to make a film everything I've been
doing
Louise has been building up to that
moment in my free time I've been
studying cinematography and stuff and
that is the one thing I want to do so I
feel like once I've done that maybe
alright well if you did ever leave Japan
how how do you think like what effect
your channel rights abroad in the UK you
almost feel the times it like maybe
you're like not say like hostage did you
can but kind of like you're like well my
job is Japan like can I leave so big not
really love do you think so but not
necessarily no yeah I mean my channel is
let's face it the reason the channel so
success was because most of my viewers
are interested in Japan right and I'm
fine with that I do have a second
channel called a broad perspective right
right you upload a lot of videos where
you just just chat ships to the comments
that you get right it's fantastic
absolutely how about charisma oh there
are applying to hate comments video
comments where you a lot of videos where
you just you know reply to comments and
those get just as many of you sometimes
as your lady so I feel like you know
even if you did leave you could easily
transition oh yeah I mean I do think if
I had to leave Japan god forbid there
would be a future I would be able to do
some sort of pivot and create a channel
that's focus on comedy or commentating
or something but really I've always seen
my youtube channel as a YouTube channel
and also a stepping stone as stepping
stone to getting into the film industry
and device in the world of film so is
that like your ultimate goal after those
multiple go and 2020 was supposed to be
I was supposed to be the year that I did
that Wow in that video that's kind of in
a bit delayed
what's going on these things move slowly
what I fear most is getting pigeon-holed
into like one type of content I love
anime right but like have you ever felt
like you wanted to make content outside
of anime or like something that's not
about Japan itself I mean that's white
like specifically anime because I do
have so many other like interesting like
things that I do I like I love anime
don't get me wrong polite I also like a
lot of other things and unfortunately I
can't really talk about that kind of
stuff without it being very unnatural
love I mean I like what you know I'm
like like before anime like I was I was
in like like four different bands are
you making yeah music I make a lot of
music like the sideline so like I've
always been very passionate about music
I've always wanted to like talk about
music and I did that a little bit on my
second channel but I obviously didn't
really pop off hold on ma try to make me
a channel Joey's like I had a bunch of
my audience which is like if you ever
like start talking about music it's just
called The Music Man and I was that
close to making a channel called the
music I'm like a 1 the API is gonna be
the one your brand you'll be the man and
then something in between yeah exactly
there's a 1 in there somewhere yeah I
mean you have to bear in mind I was
literally doing like Sebastian my whole
channel wasn't personally yeah honestly
surprised you - escape that pigeonhole I
don't know how I did it I took so many
tries I remember so many videos that I
did want that weren't that fail but I
also know I I know this is good yeah
gotta make it work I don't like what
like 5 years later are making host club
videos they're pulling way out you know
like yeah yeah yeah yeah persistent and
it's hard because you're gonna get
discouraged well no it isn't normal used
to yeah people don't like what you know
they they aren't comfortable with and
the thing is if you am sure you guys
will happen it so you you've asked your
viewers for suggestions that never one
they give you this day like do the same
thing again but slightly different
it's just like all right well you Cleve
don't know what you want yeah it's like
they don't know what they want a lot of
the times yeah and you just have to be
like III like you said right
you found a story you found the people
to talk yeah you're like maybe people
wouldn't click on you know when you
started why would someone click on that
ski the documentary right exactly but
you've built it up to the point where
okay people trust you and they
understand that you go into that I think
that's the end game with any successful
YouTube channel is to build it around
your personality yeah I spent years
getting out of yeah and I think you've
done an amazing job of doing that I mean
I watched nasca documentary and I don't
know like if you'd have pitched that to
me before I watched your channel I'd
have been like yeah no I'm okay
very good Stan but yeah I mean it's it's
that kind of evolution that you really
like strive for right there you can you
hope you can make an hour documentary on
your mate
it was just [ __ ] around in your all
right that's it's like and that's it I
think that's a like a testament to how
well you've built your you and your
brand right and that's the I mean that
yeah that's the endgame you want to got
it run yourself you want to build it
around your friends you know yeah I find
the right people to put in front of the
camera like a ski exactly it's
ridiculous but yeah